dieses war billige etwas befindet sich
unter deiner schädeldecke ein faltiger
wackelpudding bestehend aus milliarden
von nervenzellen die pausenlos auf
sendung sind und auf empfangen
darin soll unser bewusstsein unser ich
zu hause sein
aber wo genau wo stecken unsere
wahrnehmungen und gefühle und wo unsere
seele könnte es vielleicht sein dass
unser geist im grunde nichts anderes ist
als unser gehirn ist letztlich alles nur
materie also auch wir selber nichts als
materie
wer das glaubt kennt mary nicht sie ist
die führende expertin wenn es um die
wahrnehmung von farben geht
sie weiß alles über wellenlängen über
die retina vom auge und über die
verarbeitung von visuellen reizen im
gehirn
sie kennt alle wissenschaftlichen fakten
und weiß haargenau was vor sich geht
wenn wir farben ziel der haken an der
sache ist mary hat selbst noch nie einen
farbigen gegenstand gesehen weder eine
rote tomaten noch den blauen himmel
sie befindet sich nämlich seit ihrer
geburt in einem raum in dem es keine
farben gibt ihre kleider sind
schwarz-weiß ihre haare schwarz sie
kennt nur schwarz weiß und grau alles
was sie über die welt und die
farbwahrnehmung weiß hat sie in büchern
gelesen
doch eines tages öffnet sich wie von
zauberhand die tür nach draußen
mary traut ihren augen kaum auf einer
sieht sie das was jahre lang erforscht
hat farbe
bisher wusste sie zwar sehr genau was in
ihrem gehirn passieren wird wenn sie
jemals farben sehen würde
nun aber erlebten wie das ist und wie es
sich anfühlt
für mary ist klar wer draußen etwas
neues über fahren gelernt ihr wissen
über die farbwahrnehmung war
unvollständig
für sie ist damit auch klar es gibt
tatsachen die selbst eine perfekte
physikalische theorie nicht beschreiben
kann
ist unsere art die welt zu erleben also
etwas anderes als die biochemischen
vorgänge im gehirn ist unser geist mehr
als unser gehirn